[Music]
making clear that this isn't really a
presentation about do two notebooks per
se there's lots of good presentations at
this year's conference at last year's
conference as well talk about some of
the great things they're doing with the
notebooks it's more about a little sort
of some case studies I rang using the
three language that make up the name
Jupiter Python and are really I just
didn't want to but I figured it was not
much you just take Jupiter on put them
all in together and just to give you a
little bit of background I've been
involved in
I suppose waiting call numerical
computation for a number of years now
and it just seemed that for many years
every time I changed jobs up until a few
years ago every time I changed jobs they
said oh we don't care what you've done
in the past in this job we only use this
language so you know you're going to
have to learn this I'm sure a few other
people have had that sensation before so
it's like oh great I've got all this
experience of using these languages but
obviously you know best so over the
years I kind of use a number of
different languages and some some I've
enjoyed some enjoyed less but I'd like
to see sort of the pros and cons of each
really um in the main sort of the
language I've tended to try and use over
the last few years have tend to be R
which I've been using such as an
undergrad in 1998 and the last few years
I've sort of just used Python more and
more and so yep I thought postal
projects are sometimes with work and and
beginning of this year I kind of thought
cell phone along gonna do I'm going to
try knowing Julia as well because you
know I have so much free time really and
so what I thought I would do is try and
find little projects where I could write
like a little sort of pieces of code in
each of the three languages and just to
kind of I think part of the issue
sometimes when you're going between
languages just try and remember what
word you've got to use to do something
like to use some calculation and as part
of that I decide Bell so I decide to try
to find like little projects or the
other things to do and I every Friday on
the 5:00
88 blog there is what's called the
Riddler I do most people here know the
538 blog and nate silver no okay for
those who don't know nate silver is an
american sort of a data scientist so
rock star data scientist he's sometimes
called in the 2012 election he predicted
49 out of 50 states correctly he didn't
do so well in the 2016 election but then
most people didn't either I think though
he did to be fair he did give Trump the
highest probability of winning which is
about some between 25 to 30 percent so
he he did things kind of least worst out
of all the most people there um but he
still blogs about politics about sport
and data science in general and every
Friday there is like I said the Riddler
there and normally it's a problem but
there's always that kind of carb twist
like if you get this wrong you get
thrown off a moving train or get thrown
down a pit with poison spikes and there
was one little challenge in the last
year where it was basically just a
little problem there was two packs of
cards one was in suit order to his ace
king of clubs Ace King of Diamonds blah
blah blah and one was shuffled and the
idea was that you turn over one card
from each pack at the same time and if
the cards matched the values matched
then you were basically thrown off a
moving train or something like that or
shot and whereas if you actually went
through the entire pack and all the card
values were different then you ended up
winning so you end up living so I
thought for some reason it kind of
intrigued me because it was a nice
problem you could solve quite easily in
all three demon languages and actually
perhaps what I should have asked at the
beginning is how many people here have
actually used R or know of it mmm okay
that's about about 2/3 Julia okay well
so I can pre get a we're seeing a lot
more that could pretend I don't know
what everything and Python yeah okay
good
right so as I just go to the problem it
was a face simply all I had to do was
create a pack of cards shuffle them and
do a comparison so rather than comparing
all the cards were of different values I
just decided to actually check if any of
them were equal so
probably slightly eagerness close to
check losses so normally I don't like to
see in code on slides but I'm going to
break my own rule because it's my
presentation I'm kind of allowed to do
that
oops I've got to [ __ ] so this is the
Python code hopefully nothing no that's
too too much too scary
so I said just just create the pack of
cards up here I'm going because it
sounds like a competition that you might
not win often I've decided to run the
simulation a million times and I just
going to start with zero losses and so
I'm just checking that any of the cards
equal the random permutation of them as
well anything else
no coming anyhow so that was in Python
I then sort of ran the same thing again
in our again did so you can see slightly
again like pythons slightly concise as
well are and Julia unlike Python they
start at the one indexed so you start
the value one so this is how you say
range 1 to 14 just say 1 : 13 and we
have peaking at 4 times again we're
going to run it a million times
lots of 0 it doesn't have the additional
assignment operator which really bugs me
sometimes and held there I have to type
in the variable name again that's really
horrible and then you just got because
you don't have the you don't have the
same oo language that you have in Python
you can just say any equals sample of
cards so nothing there I think is too
scary I just go really different now
because also Python numpy Python and are
both have vectorized commands as it
makes it quite neat and quite concise
Julia let's give a second when I first
started looking at Julia have to
understand
doesn't have vectorization it doesn't
like it really and the one thing you
have to remember when you're trying to
write Julia code is don't fear the for
loop there is always something that
whether you're in our party you try and
avoid that as much as possible you try
and use the special commands there but
Julia your scope note you use as many
for loops as you like really so ignore
this bit for the moment but you can see
here this is so repeat repeat command is
rep Matt in Julia and go do a million
and Nasus so they've got a nice little
keyword in Julia called shut
which almost like is almost if it was
invented for cards and here we had to
create our own any function really so we
just said if there DFL is equal then we
had a loss and then you break it and
then you've got end so you don't
actually have to either indent it in in
our and Julie you don't have to indent
your code I just think it looks a bit
neater doing that way
so it's as I said it's a nice little
problem was easily solved ran the
simulations and again the result by the
way is about sixteen thousand point six
percent which is approximately 12 over
13 to the power 52 really so if you want
a project Euler kind of a quick results
well actually brighten all this
simulation code so I've got the results
are quite happy with them and I thought
well I wonder how long these things took
and so Python oh man that first of all I
would just say that my laptop is it's
quite old on that one so these results
might be slower than ones you have but
I'd like but all of them were ran it at
the same way and there was a code that
you've just seen so Python took 40 about
44 seconds so it did a million
simulations and a million up to more
than more than million equalities and
then I'll took about 14 seconds and I
was like oh that's kind of not what I
expected I had always thought that
Python would be quicker than R and I was
a bit surprised at that and we round it
over certain sort of coding events as
well other people's laptops and these
were quite consistent as well and judi
by the way came in about seven point
three seconds as well as there was twice
as quick as as R which kind of was what
I heard from other benchmarks but this
thing about our being quicken the Python
was a bit full weird for me of kind of
win against some things I'd heard and I
also checked it with other sort of numpy
commands like all or some or square root
and it was like oh this is a bit strange
and then it kind of hit me we've got a
pack of cards and there's only length 52
how many people here deal or the regular
basis of a data set of length 52 nobody
and then maybe there's a few medical
people most of us are dealing with much
bigger data sets as well so when
actually I then went back to the code
and then rolled actually in one pack of
cards I did ten or a hundred or
thousand we kind of got these results as
well I don't if this is clear to
everybody at the bottom here we've got a
number of packs of cards we're dealing
with and on the boy X's we got the time
they're both on the log 10 scale so you
can kind of see that this is these are
the results that we got from the
previous slide where you create a 10
packs you can still see that Python is
still slower than our and junior but
then once we get quitter once we get to
sort of nearer 5,000 or then 50,000 we
can now see that our is flowing really
quite badly down and the differential
between Python and Julia is still it's
getting smaller Jude is still quicker at
the time I'd be interested I probably
didn't have time to as you go up to
10,000 packs of cards really these ones
were taken quite a bit of time by the
end so if we've got so but we can kind
of see here that Python obvious has some
sort of multi-threading things set up so
that it gets far it gets faster as the
datasets increase as well are something
goes completely eschews makes it much
slower and Julia does he do still be
fairly steady as you get the datasets
grow bigger so yeah but I ran this so I
had a couple of sort case those couple
things like this and this always was the
result I then thought to myself well I
want something a little bit meteor
something a little bit more than just a
few lines of code and I kind of cheated
the next time and that sort case study I
used which was he's not here today
actually
Tariq Rashid is a guy who runs London
Python and he's often a quite keen to
make to write books about how to sort
build things from very first principles
and he wrote a very nice book called
make your own neural network and in the
book he actually explained from in basic
English houses of building your network
and explanation behind it and you also
built it using numpy Python code as well
so there's a github repository where you
can find that stuff on and I thought
that seems like a nice little thing
because let's face it at this moment in
time your networks are really cool
there's lots of nice little things that
happen in your networks there's a lot of
sort of matrix algebra
I thought well why not just draw a
translation of it into our and Julie
I've had jobs in the past we've had to
translate cones to it thing so this
seemed like a nice little project to do
and so yeah I gave myself some ground
rules the beginning which were I was
only going to use base are and so base
Julia so I didn't want to add in any
sort of fancy packages just yet I can
was in later time and I could do it as a
sort of life aligned translation a
couple of reasons for that number one it
was it meant that again I could then
work out what how you would help I put
my teeth in the the word you would use
in one language would be translate to
another language and also quite friend
if I wanted to actually add anything
sort of flashy it could we be able to a
later date and thirdly it was basically
sheer laziness really suddenly actually
gone through the hassle of actually
setting code up for you so I thought
well why not just use it as a basis for
my next code and hopefully if anybody's
here is kind of OFA with neural networks
but I think it's quite a big step to
actually just introduce the whole
concept of them as a little aside in a
presentation but there is luck there so
maybe I'll skip this one for the moment
really now the translation was actually
most it was relatively straightforward I
think as we saw with the previous slide
a lot of things particularly between arm
and - the vectorization allows you to do
a lot of things in a single line with
Julia because Julia doesn't allow
doesn't really like vectorization you
sometimes have to then go add a for loop
inside your inside your code so if you
would translate when the date was read
in you've got to translate it you had a
CSV file it was in in Python are you
split it and then convert to an integer
whereas in Julia you had to say right we
going to declare these integers and then
you then fill them up one by one - for
loop but that was kind of
a the one major difference between
translator Julia a lot of time it was
spent because a lot of matrix algebra in
her neural networks
it was spend a lot of time doing this
contracts equals a beast and a numpy
code to stuff like this well this is our
a percent store percent B I don't know
why they chose that s plus Jojo I think
when they were variety they were trying
to out weird MATLAB or something at the
time julia has a much nicer way of doing
matrix multiplication it's just a star
if your two matrices is as a star B
which kind of makes sense a couple of
the issues as well in the book there was
a neural network class as well classes
don't really exist
in art they do but not quite the same
way as they would in a spell language
they kind of appear at the end of your
code run at the beginning so but I've
got enough experience that I was able to
replicate some of that I have to admit
Julia I've very sort of been using for a
short period time I didn't have enough
experience to replicate classes in Julia
and I didn't want to try really I
figured this get the thing finished
overall and then worry about sort of
doing sort of having as much matching as
possible so managed to run those in the
book I forgot to mention the matron
neural network a it was a single single
hidden layer neural network and was used
on the Emmis dataset the Emily space set
is the 60,000 handwritten digits so that
was fed in so wrote these so wrote the R
and Julia Code Rhett train the model on
the train date set tested on the test
inator and I got the 97% accuracy that
they actually get in the book it was run
there were five epochs as well in the
code but there was that one big
difference between that and it's the
time taken and in there so complete
reversal from the last slide we in kind
of see nut Python is now quicker than
Julia and much quicker than R for
running them so our Python that for year
seconds Julia 520i was twice as slow as
pie in this case and so I was kind of a
little bit concerning that kind of
was what I was once start looking at so
I really thought that okay so this BIM
shows that our is generally slower than
Python and not quite um I was then I
started to look at profiling show it was
a little bit more complex than that
really there's a nice package in our
studio called Profis where you can
actually visualize you can got lifeline
profiling yoson you've got some nice
graphics and shows you bit more
information like that and it basically
showed that roughly 80% of the time
spent was doing a 1 a single matrix
calculation so he had this code and at
the end we had the final piece of matrix
calculate matrix multiplication and 80%
of my profiling time eight of my time
was spent doing that and I was like okay
this is a bit weird i naive you had
thought but because you don't do magic
multiplication in pure are pure Python
is done underneath in C++ in Fortran and
I thought that using C++ and Fortran it
wouldn't make much difference obviously
I was wrong
what I did find though that is the
majors calculations in are within a C++
in numpy it's done in Fortran and there
is no way I was he going to believe that
Fortran was twice as quick as C++ not
that I wish to actually and start that
flamewar all over again so I was really
kind of this became a bit of an
obsession for me why like these matrix
calculations were slower and and one of
the one of the reasons that kept coming
up was a numpy can sometimes use you
could be multi-threaded as well so our
is single threaded now Microsoft have
actually written a version have
rewritten the source code of our to
produce open R which is a multi free
version and the one thing we found is
that when I surround it a few times I
found a big speed up with matrix
calculations particularly for larger
matrices it's in basically if you've got
like a several thousand row and column
matrix it's quite embarrassing ly slow
however slow it is whereas the mobsters
version was much quicker so I
reinstalled Oh
on my laptop and it made no difference
the time taken really Thank You
Microsoft no I shouldn't be too hard on
them as well
there was actually a major reason why
this was the case there would there are
two actual issues at stake here as well
number one in our all the numeric data
types are float64 so you have this great
advantage of 64-bit pea seeds that they
actually speed up your processes
unfortunately our puts everything into a
float 64 which slows everything down
really I've got a plot it which Harry is
so over here who helped me produce this
slide we were at my whisky club on Good
Friday through these matrix timings
hopefully but we did these before we had
B whisky just to clear though everybody
what we have here are n by n matrices
they're filled with a standard standard
normal variables wasn't it
and we multiplied them together and this
was the time taken really but I'm taking
four to multiply them together on a
pretty fast computer really so we can
see at the top here that we've got this
is standard our matrix cupcake you can
see we've got this order n so n cubed
time taken for each these timings so we
start off here that's our float 64 which
is by default flood 64 then we've got
julia float64 numpy numpy and float 64
and then we have open are so open R is
pretty quicker then you could
potentially make another open R is
quicker than numpy and Julia for float64
but you wouldn't want to use float 64
you can see there's a big gap here
before we have a Julia float 32 and
numpy float 32 on our 8,000 by 8,000
matrix here so there's not much
difference lower lower end but it kind
of gets bit more pronounced higher up
and this makes its calculation that we
had wasn't anywhere near this level here
really there was no
so I just left my trailer for that
second yeah the matrix calculation that
I said it was at the end that was really
slow it was nowhere near this size it
was kind of down this size really so it
really wasn't going to be the matrix
calculation that was a problem the issue
actually was something else it was
actually four loops in are what happens
with in are when you do a for loop is
right at the ends every so often at a
random basis it would do a garbage
collection and this actually slow this
will then take time out and you could
take either however long a garbage
collection takes the issue was because I
hadn't read the manual properly long
blown profiling every 10 milliseconds
checks where you are in your code and
what it was doing it was stuck at the
end of the for loop and it was doing the
garbage collection and it assigned all
of this to this final matrix calculation
so a lot of this matrix calculation I
was looking at a lot these issues I was
trying to find I didn't need to look at
but I only found this out later on after
having gone through all this ring roll
and actually proved myself it wasn't
that issue so let there be listened to
maybe read the manual fully but it's a
mistake we've all made in our careers
and know that we're going to make it
again at some point so I found the
reason for this slowness was garbage
collection and also float64 but it
shouldn't make huge that big a
difference anyway um Julia timings Julia
in comparison to Python we saw it was
slightly slower when we've often been
told that Julia is much quicker well we
saw in the previous slide that we've got
the matrix calculations they were
slightly slower than Python as well I
wanted to actually check so that's
putting on the reasons why rules had
this slightly slower own neural network
but the earth reason why is well I
wanted also check the other a was a code
even though I just slagged off by them
so I made a mistake with profiling I
still want to see what the profiling
looked like in Julia and Julia has tries
to the nice would say is verbose
profiler if ever you
use it you will get a heck of a lot of
information and it's really difficult to
actually kind of work your way through
this as well it's something that I just
gave up after World trying to work my
way through it because so I actually
want to find out if there was anything
else that was faster slower but the
profiling was just full of a lot of
information which personally I found a
bit difficult to read so I can't really
got a better answer for you at the
moment they're just saying the matrix
calculations are slightly slower in
Julia than they are in Python if anybody
wants to have a look through so the
profiling code then they're happy I'm
happy for you show you that but I just
thought I haven't a life too short to be
doing stuff like this
um so oh well I must have missed out
couple of it's the talk but never mind
we can leave early anyway a couple of
quick sort of final thoughts um I'm
still trying to work out why we still
had this got white Python was slower for
the smaller data sets possibly it may
have been some setup costs with the
blast libraries or some of the other
areas as well be interested know if
anybody has any ideas about that so we
can maybe discuss that afterwards as
well but that said with vet right once
you get through vectorization and the
numpy libraries things do speed up as
the data get to probably the more the
biggest size that we're more users
experiencing in our daily lives other
thing as well I think are certainly to
have float32 option because otherwise
it's just going to it's just gonna get
slower and slower particularly data sets
get bigger and bigger and it needs to
sort out its issue with the for loops as
well the gobbet doing a garbage
collection just suddenly yeah you I
forgot to mention actually when I was
doing I eventually ran some code my
collected timings at the end or for loop
I just got this like little tiny drag Li
liner to me you got this big jump the
joints on his big jump and that what's
causing that shoe slowdown and if
anybody hears from Julie or any witch in
the video um basically whitelighters can
we have a nicer profiler can we have a
line-by-line profile it would be really
nice so they did actually have they do
have something which which is
interacting and visualizing but again
just give us a like a text file that you
have in Python you've got some nice
profilers there and you have in R so
that will be quite a nice thing so you
can maybe check a bit more about the how
julia works and where a lot of time is
spent okay um oh yeah sorry any
conclusion basically what language to
use okay yeah
don't ask me really I think I just say
whatever makes you happy whatever you
like the look of whatever is quite
interesting you use whatever is like
quite an interesting kind of language to
use really and failing that whatever
your boss tells you you have to use
which I've done that many times before a
couple of final bits all the code I've
used is on the github page so if you
want to sort of look at that tell me
anything I'm doing wrong the old dam I
haven't put up there the matron your
network code is actually on a separate
github page there's a I think it's just
my Oh double n as your code as a I just
found a bit of the code and now I'm just
going to do a couple of minutes just
doing some quick blatant plugs this
whole I this tool is just basically me
just about to plug plug a whole lot of
meetups I'm involved with really I'm one
of the organizers of the London cable
meetup as well so I assume most you
heard of Kegel as well I could see a few
members here already we organise
hackathons and coding events coding dojo
as well I mentioned the earlier code
with the shuffled cards and the 538
riddle we start we looked at those over
a couple of dojo events as well and so
compared results across a couple
computers so we have a hackathon where
we didn't spend all Saturday work on ko
competitions that's on we're going to
have next one on Saturday the 27th of
May I've got to say big thank you Ben is
here from my jar he's going to be
hosting the event that's next we also
host have our and Python coding dojos as
well they've eventually
months Harry who I've mentioned here did
this a lot help with my helpers get the
matrix calculations heme and Antonio
organized a project oiler meet up for
those who don't know Paula is a website
where they have mathematical
competitions on so if you should like
going down the pub and work on pen and
paper this is a really good meter if you
do remember of so they go in a pub and
they solve mathematical problems Harry
and I also harry has also set up a
coding challenge meet up as well I'm one
of the co-organizers of that the
basically point of that one is that if
you are interested doing hacker rank
coding Wars or gaming AI problems just
come along and just say I'm stuck in
this problem and they will form a team
and load your work on that one as well
and finally Tirico have mentioned who
wrote the book maker in your network
runs the london python meetup and
algorithmic art as well so i think i'm
coming in about two minutes under half
an hour but those who work on finish but
so thank you all for your time yep yep
sure if anyone any questions please fire
away
No okay oh sorry yes yeah okay okay okay
I'm just repeat the questions for you
could I mean I was asked if there's a
difference between the random number
generators whether not written didn't
think so oh you mean like in the earned
it was numpy MP random but permutation I
did try a couple of others I didn't find
any difference there was MP random
choice and sample as well
yeah I've run those and that didn't see
any difference between them okay
thank you thank you okay yeah no no also
yet the next cago hackathon we're going
to announce that sometime this week we
know we give you with two or three weeks
notice beforehand
[Music]